[Musique]
des marionnettes de cette facture vous
n'en verrez nulle part ailleurs
on les croyait disparues avant de les
retrouver à beaugency en 2016 des pièces
réalisées dans les années 30 par marcel
temporal à leurs précurseurs d'un
nouveau genre de figurines qu'à l'époque
on faisait des mariannes être très
traditionnel guignols très réaliste et
marseille temporalité aussi un
architecte un publiciste un sculpteur il
a fait des marionnettes qui était tout à
fait dans l'esprit de l'époque sur l'art
déco avec mon voit par exemple sur cette
femme aux cheveux blonds très étonnant
des formes très très cubiste très
arrondi jeu personnages également il a
amené quelque chose de totalement
novateur marcel temporal connu un succès
international
enseignants et transmis le fil à une
génération de marionnettistes son fils
jean loup fait partie de ceux qui
reprirent l'héritage mais dans un style
bien à lui
marcel temporal mais faisait fabriquer
sculptées dans du bois
ces marionnettes avec ses idées avec ses
formes à lui et jean no temporal au
début il a fait ses propres marionnettes
mais après pour ses spectacles pour les
spectacles surtout pour adultes il
faisait appel à chaque spectacle à des
artistes particulier les rites h et la
manipulation c'est aussi de l'esprit des
spectacles
c'est ça peut être l'esprit des
marionnettes principales sont des
personnages qui se ressemblent au niveau
du caractère et ils se ressemblent parce
qu'ils sont parfaitement adaptés au
public d'enfants les temporal père fils
et petit-fils 3 génération de
marionnettistes s'expose à beaugency
durant tout l'été
un rendez vous unique en france